- [Instructor] We are told
a student hangs blocks
with different masses
from a pulley of mass, M,
and radius, r,
and releases them from rest.
The student measures
the time of the fall, t,
and the magnitude of the
angular velocity, omega sub f,
when the block reaches a distance, d,
below the axle.
There is considerable friction
between the axle and pulley.
Which of the following plots
could show the student's measurements
as a function of the applied
torque on the pulley?
So pause this video
and see if you can figure
it out on your own.
All right, so let's first
understand what these axes are,
and then we'll talk a little bit
about what's going on with
this mass pulley system.
So, on our horizontal axis here,
we have our applied torque.
Now where is the applied
torque in this system?
Well, you're going to have some mass here,
and we assume we're on a planet
or probably on Earth.
So you're going to have
gravity pulling down on this,
so you're gonna have the force
of the weight of this object
pulling down,
and we know that this has radius, r.
So that force times that radius
is going to be the applied torque.
And of course, the more mass you have,
the more weight you're going to have,
and you're going to have more torque.
So this is really showing
that as the student applies
larger and larger masses,
right over here,
we're going to have more
and more and more torque.
Now, what is in our vertical
axis right over here?
Omega sub f divided by t.
So this is our final angular velocity,
once this thing has
gone down a distance, d,
that's what they tell us,
divided by the time it took to get there.
Well, if we assume that it
started from a standstill,
you could view this as
your angular acceleration.
So this is the angular acceleration
as a function of applied torque.
So I could write angular
acceleration right over there,
or you could say your
average angular acceleration
over that time period.
From when you start to time, t.
So what do we think would happen?
Well, if you have small masses here,
it would create a small torque.
But if you have considerable friction,
which they talk about right over here.
There is considerable friction
between the axle and pulley.
So for small masses right over here,
the torque will likely
not be strong enough
to overcome the friction.
And in that situation,
you would not have any
angular acceleration.
Everything would just stay still.
But then at some point,
once your mass gets large
enough, right over here,
then your torque would be large enough
to overcome the friction in
between the axle and the pulley.
So which of these graphs describe that?
Or which of these plots?
Well, this first one,
describes a situation when
you have a low applied torque,
you have a high angular acceleration.
That does not make sense,
so we should rule that out.
This one kinda shows angular acceleration
is indifferent to applied torque.
And that doesn't make sense.
The more applied torque you have,
the larger masses here,
well then you should have
more angular acceleration.
So that doesn't make sense.
Now, both of these show an upward trend
where as you have more applied torque,
you have more angular acceleration.
So which of these would you pick?
Well, this one here, on the right,
this kind of paints a picture
that as soon as you
have any applied torque,
you start having angular acceleration.
And if this was a frictionless system
or if there was very little friction here,
maybe this would make sense.
But as we talked about,
for low masses,
which should have a low weight,
so it would generate low applied torque,
it wouldn't be able to overcome friction.
And so you should not have
some angular acceleration for low torques,
but then as the torque gets larger,
you will overcome the friction
and then start to accelerate the system.
And so I would pick B.